[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 2019 team russia llevaron su relación
un paso más allá
ambos países elevaron su cooperación al
grado de abro comillas a asociación
estratégica integral de coordinación
global que como os quedáis sea como sea
lo cierto es que hablamos del mejor
momento en la relación entre estas dos
potencias dos países que en tiempos de
mao llegaron a protagonizar un montón de
rifirrafes fronterizos el caso es que
este buen entendimiento debería suponer
un impulso a la organización de
cooperación de shanghai habéis escuchado
hablar de ella se trata de una
institución formal liderada por pekín y
moscú que tiene como punto de atención
asia central sin embargo amigos el
futuro de esta organización regional
ofrece más interrogantes que certezas
entre otras cosas porque parece que los
intereses de china y rúsia no discurren
por los mismos caminos
así que envíos al político nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas en qué
consiste exactamente esta organización
de cooperación de shanghai
y realmente se llevan tan bien rusia y
china- y la cuestión que resulta aún más
importante qué futuro tiene la relación
entre estos dos gigantes hoy en visual
político vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poquito de historia
[Música]
pero stop un momento y mucha muchísima
atención
[Música]
antes de seguir queremos presentaros un
nuevo proyecto con el que estamos
colaborando si lo hubiera sabido un
nuevo canal de información financiera
con el que podréis estar al día de todo
lo que ocurre en los mercados pilotado
por mucho activos este canal aspira a
convertirse en todo una ventana al mundo
del dinero las bolsas y la renta
variable
por ejemplo sabías que la inversión en
bolsa protegió a los inversores durante
las grandes crisis e incluso la
mismísima argentina del corralito cómo
se están recuperando exactamente las
principales economías tras el impacto
del coronavirus cuál ha sido la mayor
opv del año china cómo funcionan
exactamente los mercados estos son
queridos amigos amigas algunas de las
preguntas a las que este nuevo canal de
mutuactivos pretende responder y echarle
un vistazo y no olvidéis suscribiros
merece la pena lo vais a poder comprobar
por vosotros mismos os dejamos por aquí
también en la descripción un enlace a su
primer vídeo y al canal y dicho esto
arranquemos
[Música]
unidos contra las tres fuerzas del mal
moscú está mucho más cerca de madrid que
de pekín así que aunque china y rusia
comparten fronteras a sus gobernantes
siempre les ha separado algo más de seis
mil kilómetros de distancia pese a ello
se han cruzado un montón de veces por el
camino
la primera mitad del siglo 20 una época
revolucionaria tanto para rusia como
para china el imperio ruso se transformó
en la unión de repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas mientras que el imperio chino
culminó su colapso dando paso a una
república dividida y amenazada
continuamente por japón' derrotados los
nipones en la segunda guerra mundial el
partido comunista de china se alzó
victorioso en la guerra civil rusia y
china- pasaban a estar unidas al menos
desde un punto de vista ideológico
la guerra fría dividió el mundo en dos
grandes bloques la urss y china se
unieron como las grandes potencias
comunistas aliadas contra el occidente
capitalista sin embargo amigos todo se
torció tras la muerte de stalin digamos
que quedó vacante el título de macho
alfa del comunismo y así comenzó una
enorme rivalidad entre moscú y pekín por
ver quién era el más comunista de todos
y mao mao ha puesto fuerte tan lejos
llegó la disputa que en 1969 hubo
enfrentamientos entre las tropas
soviéticas y chinas a lo largo de la
frontera
el reino quedó todo desde principios de
los años 70 china comenzó a cooperar con
eeuu para formar una pinza con la que
frenar a la unión soviética de esta
forma hasta finales de los años 80 la
urss mantuvo 44 divisiones desplegadas a
lo largo de sus más de 6000 kilómetros
de frontera con china 13 divisiones más
que las que tenía apostadas en el frente
occidental contra la otan en cualquier
caso tras la caída de la unión soviética
en los años 90 comenzó un acercamiento
entre rusia y china- que da lugar a los
shanghai faith y si este podría ser el
nombre del grupo más rompedor del pop
chino pero no en realidad es todo
shanghai five eran china-rusia y tres
antiguas repúblicas soviéticas
kazajistán kirguistán y tayikistán los
cinco se reunieron por primera vez en
shanghai en 1996 y precisamente de ahí
procede el nombre de los shanghai five
estas reuniones tenían un objetivo muy
claro resolver de una vez por todas las
disputas fronterizas las ya clásicas
entre china y rúsia y otras más
recientes que surgieron tras la
disolución de la urss el caso es que los
cinco de shanghai siguieron reuniéndose
hasta que en 2001 decidieron dar uno
más
[Música]
uzbekistán quiero sumarse al grupo y
tanto moscú como pekín entendieron que
aquellas reuniones podrían transformarse
en toda una organización internacional
donde abordar los asuntos de asia
central así que los shanghai five más 8x
time crearon en 2001 la oce s la
organización de cooperación de shanghai
con sede en atentos amigos que esta es
pregunta de trivial porque su sede no se
fijó en shanghai sino que se estableció
en pekín respecto al funcionamiento de
la organización la carta de la oce s
recogió el compromiso de que las
decisiones oficiales se tomarían por
consenso y que ningún miembro se metería
en los asuntos internos del resto
también entonces se firmó a otro
documento fundamental hablamos de la
convención de shanghai para combatir las
tres fuerzas del mal y claro viendo el
historial de los dirigentes algún que
otro mal pensado podría pensar que esas
tres fuerzas del mal son la democracia
la libertad y la independencia de la
justicia
ais como sois algunos no amigos esas
tres fuerzas del mal son el terrorismo
el separatismo y el extremismo islamista
y sabéis qué
seis estados se tomaron muy pero que muy
en serio la lucha contra estas tres
amenazas y desde luego china era el
principal interesado en que así fuera
[Música]
la región autónoma de xinjiang la más
occidental de china es un auténtico
polvorín habitado mayoritariamente por
etnias musulmanas especialmente los
uigures que el partido comunista ha
multiplicado la presencia de ciudadanos
de etnia hand la predominante en el
resto del país sin jan limita con
tayikistán y kazajistán por eso la
estabilidad en asia central es
importante para la seguridad interna de
china digamos que pekín pretende que
estos países mantengan a raya el
extremismo islamista mientras que dentro
de sus fronteras reprime a las señas
musulmanas sin que ninguno de sus
vecinos se atreva a levantar la voz
contra el gigante chino
es la ventaja que tiene que todos los
países de la css han regímenes
autoritarios que eso de los derechos
humanos pues siempre es algo secundario
en cualquier caso lo cierto es que el
acs logró importantes avances en su
particular cooperación contra las tres
fuerzas del mal es más sus miembros
realizan frecuentemente maniobras
militares conjuntas
pero amigos la prueba de fuego para esta
alianza llegó en 2014 cuando el cree él
mismo ordenó la invasión de crimea
occidente castigo con sanciones
económicas a rusia sin embargo pekín
nunca le hizo un solo reproche a putin
más bien todo lo contrario
miller
franz
[Música]
pero esto es un momento amigos porque
desde entonces la oce se ha ampliado sus
miras en 2017 por ejemplo se
incorporaban a la organización dos
nuevos miembros
india y pakistán de esta forma la
organización se expandía hacia el índico
y ganaba peso como una alianza nueva
internacional dentro del nuevo orden
mundial cumple así con el gran objetivo
que moscú y especialmente pekín se había
marcado de qué objetivo estamos hablando
pues atentos
el nuevo orden mundial amigos la entrada
de india y pakistán ha hecho que la opcs
duplique su dimensión y puede que no
hayas escuchado hablar de la oce s pero
lo cierto es que esta organización
abarca más de 34 millones de kilómetros
cuadrados ni más ni menos que el 60 por
ciento de la región euroasiática al
tiempo que aglutina más de 3 mil
millones de personas que aproximadamente
es la mitad de la población mundial
además cuatro miembros de esta
organización rusia china pakistán e
india son estados con armas nucleares es
decir que no hablamos precisamente de
una organización poco importante la opcs
tendría el potencial de convertirse en
una de las organizaciones
internacionales más importantes del
mundo y eso eso es algo que sabe hasta
el 'tío sam' durante los primeros años
de la oce s los mismísimos eeuu
solicitaron entrar bajo el estatus de
estado observador esta condición suele
ser el paso previo a formar parte de la
organización y permite participar en sus
reuniones
miembro de la misma sin embargo su
solicitud fue rechazada y no sólo eso la
situación en afganistán e irak presagia
una presencia indefinida de fuerzas
estadounidenses en uzbekistán y
kirguistán así que la opcs pidió
oficialmente a eeuu que retirara sus
tropas de los estados que formaban parte
de la acs algo que sucedió finalmente en
2014 todo un plantón ahora bien mantener
a eeuu lejos de asia central no ha sido
su único objetivo de hecho podemos
considerar que la voz es es un
instrumento más de la estrategia de
china para construir organizaciones
internacionales al margen de las
instituciones que eeuu de diseño al
acabar la segunda guerra mundial
[Música]
este es uno de los grandes temas
internacionales las potencias
occidentales se han mostrado reacias a
modificar las cuotas de poder dentro de
la organización mundial del comercio el
fondo monetariointernacional vuelvan con
mundial de una manera que refleje la
creciente influencia económica y
política de china en respuesta china y
rúsia se han aliado para crear nuevos
foros y organizaciones en las que ambas
tengan la voz cantante en esta línea
situamos la opcs o también por ejemplo
el banco asiático de inversión en
infraestructura que invade ámbitos del
banco mundial
[Música]
pensando un segundo la guerra fría
enfrentó cara a cara dos bloques dos
visiones del mundo tras la caída de la
unión soviética los valores liberales la
democracia los derechos humanos eran los
valores dominantes en la escena global
pero hoy en día eso ya no hace
exactamente así
china está actualmente desafiando ese
orden mundial el kremlin entre mí se ha
sumado para justificar su autoritarismo
los líderes del mundo libre siguen
bajando sus estándares y los
autoritarios siguen ganando terreno de
vez en cuando la gente se despierta y
pregunta por que putin asesinan el reino
unido o piratean eeuu porque no iba a
hacerlo vosotros no lo de tuvisteis
antes
gary kasparov gran maestro ruso del
ajedrez y activista político pero al
mismo tiempo que china y rusia han
plantado cara occidente ambas potencias
también han tratado de sacar el máximo
provecho del buen momento por el que
atraviesan sus relaciones diplomáticas
[Aplausos]
por ejemplo rusia es rica en recursos
naturales y los que seguís visual
polític desde hace tiempo sabéis que la
energía es un ámbito en el que china
tiene un hambre atroz de hecho una
cuarta parte de las exportaciones de
crudo de rusia se dirigen a china y de
cara al futuro
pekín ambición al gas ruso y
precisamente por eso la estatal china
cnpc posee una quinta parte de un
megaproyecto de gas natural licuado en
el ártico ruso desarrollado por novatech
a finales del 2019
empezó a funcionar el gasoducto power
aux y vería que estará a pleno
rendimiento en 2025 hay incluso
negociaciones para un segundo gasoducto
de completarse ambos rusia suministraría
china más gas natural que el que
actualmente exporta a alemania china es
insaciable y ya sabéis quiere más y más
para que os hagáis una idea ha comenzado
a llegar tanto dinero a rusia desde
china y el 14% de sus reservas de moneda
extranjera ya son joan es algo
completamente impensable en cualquier
otro país pero un momento porque si
pensáis que lo único que le interesa a
putin es la pasta china no no hablamos
nivel no del smi de ramen no estáis muy
equivocados
el régimen comunista al otro lado del
río amur tiene mucho que ofrecer a de
kremlin fijaos china y rúsia invierte
millones en esta startup para reconocer
tu rostro las 105 mil cámaras de
reconocimiento facial de moscú llegan
para quedarse mientras el sistema
judicial del país afianza la
videovigilancia y esto amigos es sólo la
punta del iceberg de como moscú quiere
aprovechar la tecnología china otro
ejemplo
huawei desarrollará el 5 g/l rusia claro
que acá me de toda esta fuente de dinero
tecnología china quiere ampliar el
alcance de la oce s con una estrategia a
largo plazo para integrar económicamente
a todo el continente asiático la opcs
sería de este modo una vía fundamental
para conectar la costa este de china con
los mercados de asia central rusia y
europa sin embargo amigos amigas que
pekín consiga su objetivo no será tan
sencillo porque
atentos
abrazo del panda
[Música]
si nos ha convertido en la gran
superpotencia de asia central gracias a
su espectacular despertar económico
controla economías vecinas como la
kazaja la tayika y los pk además se ha
convertido en el principal socio de
türkmenistán un país que si no entra en
la uc ese es porque sus dictadores creen
que türkmenistán debe ser neutral por
encima de todo pero mucho ojo con los
datos porque lo verdaderamente
importante es que rusia tampoco es ajena
al poderío chino
en 1990 el pib de la unión soviética era
más del doble de grande que el de china
hoy en día la situación ha cambiado
radicalmente el pib de china es seis
veces mayor que el de rusia y mientras
rusia apenas ocupa el décimo lugar entre
los mercados de exportación de china
ligeramente por encima de filipinas
quien es el segundo mercado de
exportación más grande para rusia
después de la unión europea
el lado bueno de esta relación económica
ya lo hemos visto rusia necesita a china
como un mercado gigantesco al que
exportar sus materias primas pero
comerciar con china también tiene
riesgos hablemos por ejemplo de
armamento
rusia es el mayor proveedor de equipos
militares de china en la década pasada
proporcionó el 70 por ciento de las
importaciones de armas del gigante
asiático pekín ha comprado su armamento
más avanzado como los aviones sukoi e 75
y los sistemas antiaéreos s-400 sin
embargo amigos todo indica que en el
futuro china no necesitará importar
tantas armas rusas porque digo esto pues
por noticias como éstas rusia en pie de
guerra por el robo chino de tecnología
militar la principal agencia rusa de
diseño de submarinos sufre un ciber
ataque con características chinas cine
rusia han sido tradicionalmente rivales
y este tipo de noticias puede despertar
la desconfianza del kremlin algo que
también tiene consecuencias para la opcs
por un lado rusia se ha negado
rotundamente a que la opcs se convierta
en un área de libre comercio no quiere
que los productos chinos inunden el
mercado ruso y arruinen a sus
productores
[Música]
por otro lado el kremlin me ha sido el
principal impulsor de la entrada de
india en la opcs y mucho ojo porque esta
expansión hacia el índico
puede haber significado que esta
organización haya quedado herida de
muerte sí sí de muerte entre otras cosas
porque si rusia se salió con la suya al
incorporar a la india para contrarrestar
el excesivo peso de china dentro de la
organización pero es que pekín exigió
también la entrada de su firme aliado
paquistaní y claro juntar a indios y
paquistaníes en la misma sala no puede
salir bien mirad un día abandona la
reunión de la oce s después de que el
representante paquistaní proyectó un
mapa ficticio recordad que la opcs toma
todas sus decisiones por unanimidad así
que parece que la organización de
cooperación de shanghai se ha pegado un
tiro en el pie
y luego además tenemos que tener en
cuenta que tanto china como rusia tienen
su propio plan b para la región pekín
lleva años trabajando la nueva ruta de
la seda una inversión multimillonaria en
infraestructuras con las que extender la
influencia económica y comercial de
china en el mundo y moscú moscú liberal
la unión económica eurasiática un
proyecto que pretende imitar a la
comunidad económica europea el germen de
la actual unión europea al final la
clave de todo esto es que rusia sigue
queriendo tratar de tú a tú a china y
claro hay serias dudas de que realmente
pueda hacerlo pero la cuestión la
cuestión más importante es que todas
estas controversias nos muestran una
realidad que no siempre se tiene en
cuenta las relaciones entre rusia y
china- no son tan buenas como aparentan
ser pero llegados hasta aquí turno para
ti crees que la organización de
cooperación de shanghai puede tener
futuro consideráis que rusia se
beneficia de su buena relación comercial
con china o corre peligro de convertirse
en un rehén más de pekín podéis dejarnos
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios
si el vhio te ha gustado
no olvides darle al botón de like y
tampoco suscribirte avisa al político
que aún no lo has hecho un saludo
hasta la próxima
[Música]